estas serán las últimas columnas de humo
que emane la chimenea de la central
nuclear de un dren mean game pues a la
medianoche del 31 de diciembre este
reactor del sur de alemania cerrará
definitivamente junto con las centrales
de grundy brutal en el norte del país de
este modo sólo quedan tres reactores
nucleares en funcionamiento que se
cerrarán a finales de 2022
la decisión de eliminar la energía
nuclear fue tomada por la ex canciller
angela merkel hace una década tras el
devastador desastre de la central de
fukushima en japón y ahora los empleados
de las tres centrales alemanas
comenzarán el largo proceso de
desmantelamiento de los reactores
contra mí me alegro de que tengamos
empleados en el lugar que conocen la
central que están calificados y que
saben lo que hace y este periodo de
desmantelamientos durará seguramente una
o dos décadas más alemania- aspira a que
las energías renovables como la eólica y
la solar representen el 80 por ciento de
su producción en 2030 mientras tanto el
país planea llenar el vacío con gas
natural pero los precios de este
combustible fósil están subiendo
rápidamente mientras europa a una crisis
energética agravada por las tensiones
con rusia el principal proveedor de gas
del bloque y el canciller colapso se
enfrenta a otro reto el abandono de la
energía nuclear podría afectar el
objetivo del gobierno de reducir las
emisiones de co2 el ministro de
medioambiente ha advertido que alemania
no alcanzará sus objetivos climáticos
para 2022 y posiblemente tampoco lo haga
para el 2023